We are on problem 12.
I had to take a pause because I
had a hunger pang, but I had
to resist. Because I do this
thing called the Warrior Diet,
which is more of a
way of life-- but
anyway, back to the SAT.
But you shouldn't starve
yourself because you have to
feed your brain for the SAT.
OK, let me draw the
x- and y-axis.
Whenever I'm hungry, I just go
outside and do some sprints
because that's the
warrior way.
That's the y-axis.
But you shouldn't do
that because you're
probably still growing.
I, unfortunately, have
stabilized at 5'9".
All right, so let's see, they
drew something that looks like
a parabola, so I'm going to
assume it is without better
information.
So let me draw it.
My thing does not look like
a parabola, but I
think you get the point.
And then they draw this
rectangle-looking thing.
I'll draw it in another color.
Something like that.
Let's see, let me label
these points.
Points q, r, s, this is t.
And they say that this
is-- oh, p, p not t.
And this is point
negative 1, 0.
So obviously the y is 0 because
we're on the x-axis
and that's negative
1 and that's 1.
They tell us in the figure
above p, q, r, s is a
rectangle and points q and r lie
on the graph of y equals
ax squared.
And that's this thing,
this yellow thing.
Where a is a constant.
If the perimeter of pqrs is 10,
what is the value of a?
If we can figure out one ordered
pair, if we can figure
out one x-y pair that lie on
this curve, we can figure out
what the curve is because we
can substitute that y and x
into this equation
and solve for a.
Well, do we know any points
that are on that?
Well, both r and q are on it,
so if we can figure out the
coordinates of r and q,
then we will be set.
So what can we do?
Well, they told us
a perimeter.
They told us the perimeter
of this rectangle.
So what do we know about
the rectangle already?
How long is this side
right here?
Well, it goes 1 unit to the left
on the x-axis and it goes
1 to the right and it's flat.
So that has a width
of 2, right?
It's a rectangle, so if that
has a width of 2, this also
has a width of 2, right?
Let's call this height.
That's the height of
the rectangle.
If that's the height, that's
also the height.
So what's the perimeter?
The perimeter is 2 plus 2, which
is 4, plus h plus h.
And that equals what?
They told us that equals 10.
So we can add those
h's together.
We get 4 plus 2h
is equal to 10.
Or subtract 4 from both sides.
2h is equal to 6.
Divide both sides by 2.
h is equal to 3.
So we know that h equals 3.
So if h equals 3, what
is the point r?
Well we know that its
x-coordinate is 1 out, so it's
1, and then what's
the y-coordinate?
Well, this height right
here is 3, right?
And we're starting at 0,
so we go 3 up from 0.
So this is going to
be 3 right here.
So the r's coordinate is 1, 3.
And r is on the yellow parabola,
so now we are set.
We can take this and substitute
x and y here.
We know y is equal to 3
when x is equal to 1.
So 1 squared, right?
x squared.
So 3 is equal to a times
1 squared is 1.
So a is equal to 3 because
that one doesn't matter,
right? a is equal to
3 so we just write
down 3 inside there.
Next problem.
Problem 13.
If a times b plus b is equal
to a plus 2c, what is the
value of b when a is equal
to 2 and c is equal to 3?
So a real quick thing that we
can do just to maybe simplify
things for us is we can factor
out the b out of this side.
What do I mean by factoring
out a b?
Well, divide both of these terms
by b and you get b times
a plus 1 is equal
to a plus 2c.
All right, let me box this out
so you don't get confused.
All I did is I undistribute
the b, right?
You can multiply this back
out and you'd get
ab is equal to b.
And then if you want to solve
for b, divide both sides by a
plus 1 and you get b is equal
to a plus 2c over a plus 1.
And then you substitute.
So a is 2, so it's 2 plus 2
times c, c is 3, 2 times 3
over 2 plus 1, which is equal
to 2 plus 6 over 3, which is
equal to what?
8/3.
Another way you could have done
it-- and it might have
been even faster, actually--
is just to
substitute from the beginning.
So you say a is 2, so that would
give us 2b plus b right?
I just, a is 2 is equal to 2
plus 2 times c, 2 plus 6.
So you get 2b plus b,
so what's 2b plus b?
That's 3b.
3b is equal to 2 plus 6, 8.
Actually this would
have been faster.
8 divided by 3.
So those are two ways you
could have done it, and
hopefully you'll do them
one of the two ways.
Hopefully you'll do
it the faster way.
Next problem.
14.
Bunch of lines for me to draw.
I do so much for you guys.
The only thing I get in return
is the satisfaction of you
guys getting a perfect
score on the SAT.
I'm going to take these videos
down before I have kids,
though, so they don't
have competition.
Let's see, OK.
I'm kidding.
The competition will only
make them stronger.
I don't have kids yet, by the
way, but one day I will.
And they'll have to compete
against you guys, who I've
given this edge to.
That's how selfless I am.
And anyway, back
to the problem.
So we have this-- I'm only
partially serious.
OK, this is l, this
is a, b, c.
This is angle y, y degrees.
This out here is angle
x, x degrees.
In the figure above, m is
parallel to n, so this is m,
this is n, they are parallel.
Fair enough?
And l bisects angle abc.
So what does bisect mean?
That means that it splits the
angle perfectly, so that tells
us that angle is equivalent
to this angle.
OK?
If y is between 45 and
55, what is one
possible value for x?
So let's just say that y is 50
and see what we can do here.
So if y is 50, right?
That satisfies, this is
between 45 and 55.
What is this larger angle
here that I'm
going to do in magenta?
Well, it's a corresponding
angle, right?
Because it's a parallel line,
k is a transversal, so this
magenta angle corresponds
to y.
So it will also be
equal to 50.
And we know l bisects this
angle, so both of these
smaller angles are going
to be 25 and 25.
And now l is a transversal
as well.
So if l is 25, this angle
right here is 25.
Let me do that in
another color.
No, that color was
too similar.
I'll do it in red.
If this right here is 25, what
angle is this going to be?
Well once again, corresponding
angles of a transversal, so
this is also going to be 25.
And now what could x be?
Well, x is opposite to this
angle, so it's also going to
be 25 degrees.
So this is just the angle
game on steroids.
And you really didn't have to do
the range, you just pick a
number. y is 50, corresponding
angle is also 50.
That corresponding angle is
bisected, so each of these
smaller angles is 25.
And then l is a transversal
again, so if this is 25, this
is 25, and x is opposite.
So it's also 25.
I'll see you in the
next video.